welcome to this video playing H escape
um T keinen or something is this
marcucci kinda yes man okay we get a no
chicopee noni let's play that set up
with g3 and never have studied it in big
detail so one point is that why it is
always ready to play F for the right
moment 5f form maybe maybe that was a
good moment for him to play that night
at five coming I feel that I have had
this on the board before okay let's
cover c4 that's often useful when the
night comes to e5 that c4 is not hanging
yeah so he decides to open that if I
take with the bishop d6 hang so what is
he doing then Knight takes I don't know
and I takes 95 I mean then I can check
on f5 play 90 form yeah i'm not sure but
let's do it let's go let's go ahead and
still have more space in this position
so Bishop g5 on 95 95 or 96 looks quite
strong actually that's often the issue a
sec 6 square which is weak and based on
White's space advantage can often be a
big problem okay chick once then and now
he cannot take here twice at the end I
have Quinn d5 47 on or something like
that I really don't believe in that hmm
he wants to play that it seems I'm takes
Knight takes Queen t5 don't get it 25
then is 7 and over
running a piece so okay yeah he doesn't
have to take off course maybe he has
some funky tricks look be two or so for
Knight f3 check but I have 25 anyway so
here Bishop d5 was my original idea or
something else
it also looks quite good actually when I
def for maybe he can play Bishop f6 here
I can probably play Bishop f 6 cm which
I am underestimated does it play that ok
I thought he's seven would be
interesting here
half it maybe not at the end there's
always see for hanging I don't know come
on let's do that 9726 time is time is
running low rook f7 this Bishop g5 so
it's probably not big problem
maybe I just win c5 ya can take c5
matey's God rook c8 somehow
and 93 by the way through Kim
what a tricky position Kim with
hindsight I probably should have done
something else it's possible that is
actually quite okay for me but it's not
a position that I do understand very
well just pure pure calc let's say I
tend to screw up them okay so many
communities let's activate some pieces
here I don't know rookie 5 let's let's
do that night c4 probably look you for
this interesting
what a mess 1396 and okay five it's a
bit I don't know what you should do now
is that really the key is 94 joke okay
for yes Bishop d4 as well so that's not
that great actually this is a it's not
easy to play against with all the all
kinds of stuff hanging let's take here
tonight only six covers G covers deform
cannot take unfortunately g7 I mean
I didn't see that move coming and not at
all
check and that that's it with any hopes
of a niche time warning
samba tender one time check here we'll
take them not much to do really gah I
games like this gran gran games like
this always cost a couple of points
because I actually take the draw and not
win on time champ Wow no no well don't
don't really know what's what's going on
here that's probably somehow okay for me
but conscious place we should be fire
it's much easier maybe I should have
done that yeah this is this lee 22 huge
complications that i really don't know
what to make of night and for cheer comp
leaves are much better here but i did
not see Queen f-4s better okay or queen
of three
Queen f3 then don't ask me why this is
so good computer gives 1.9 and it wants
to play Knight deform night f 496 screen
b8 simply just giving an exchange why is
it so strong this night x just have an
idea maybe it is it's quite difficult
always this is a pure peace play
position there's no kind of structure or
whatever yeah this is probably religious
/ possible and then g4 and teeth or an
idea jassim this is the point Wow yeah
some Shack some Q checkmates check check
check mate sure honey now ok i was i was
so too rookie aid would have been tricky
and that is pointed out by the comp
getting into the pin here it actually
seems to win for him and i have no I
have no way to unpin and 94 is coming
Jim check guarantee i think it's just a
draw I mean it's really just a draw I
mean I played it a bit a bit stupid way
to not even try pretend for something
but it is really really just to draw
probably okay well thanks for watching